wow es ist realität eine wort blase
wurde erschaffen tatsächlich wurde bei
einem experiment eine blase erzeugt
schneller als das licht durch die
unendlichen weiten des weltraums könnte
damit möglich werden eine reise zu
proxima centauri unserem nachbar
sternensystem beispielsweise innerhalb
nur weniger jahre mit hilfe des web
antriebs könnte das klappen wird der
warp antrieb also realität klicks im
flugzeug gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen
es gibt nur wenig wirkliche wendepunkte
in der wissenschaft das hier könnte so
einer sein eigentlich experimentierte
drlg sunny weit vom limit space institut
lsa mit dem qasimi effekt bei dem zwei
parallele leitfähige platten im vakuum
durch eine kraft zusammengedrückt werden
dabei haben die forschenden eine mini
walkers entdeckt bezeichnet die blase
gegenüber seydi brief als reale wenn
auch kleine und sehr schwache blase das
ist wirklich ein absoluter hammer die
meisten kennen den bohrbetrieb wohl aus
den star trek film reisen durch den
weltraum mit seinen unendlichen weiten
und gigantischen distanzen ist somit
kein problem so heißt es einfach bock 9
energie und schon fliegen die lichtjahre
nur so dahin zu schön um wahr zu sein
und so tüfteln forschungsteams weltweit
daran weltraumreisen schneller zu machen
254 tage lang brauchte der mars rover
curiosity für die reise zum roten
planeten aktuelle raketen würden zu
unserem nachbar stern proxima centauri
mehr als 50.000 jahre brauchen ein
lichtstrahl benötigt immerhin noch vier
ganze jahre dorthin eine reise die ein
menschenleben also lange lange nicht
überleben würde um die wir so selbst mit
den besten technischen hilfsmitteln die
uns zur verfügung stehen deswegen nie
antreten können gesucht wird also ein
antrieb der schneller ist als das licht
damit wir menschen noch weiter in den
weltraum vordringen können doch wie
können dadurch weltraumreisen zu proxima
centauri realisiert werden und wie passt
das alles mit dem und regeln der physik
zusammen die spannenden antworten auf
all diese fragen gibt es jetzt hier bei
kings zum science and future
geschwindigkeiten schneller als das
licht sind eigentlich unmöglich lauter
speziellen relativitätstheorie wird ein
raumschiff mit steigender
geschwindigkeit immer schwerer die
erzeugt der energie geht mit der
annäherung an die lichtgeschwindigkeit
immer mehr in die masse ein und nicht
mehr in die bewegungsenergie und die
allgemeine und die spezielle
relativitätstheorie
wurden 100 fach belegt an ihnen führt
kein weg dran vorbei sie sind gültig
punkt und zwar ein ganz dicker punkt
allerdings gibt es im weltraum ein
seltsames phänomen galaxien entfernen
sich von uns mit
überlichtgeschwindigkeit und des rätsels
lösung ist eine besonderheit des raums
er kann sich nämlich schneller als mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit aus den für die
raumzeit selbst also die grund matrix
des universums gelten einstands regel
nicht in ihr allerdings sind sie gültig
aber könnte man sich diese eigenschaft
der raumzeit zunutze machen der theorie
zufolge müsste ein funktionsfähiger warp
antrieb in der lage sein das raum zeit
gebiet um das rasche so zu verändern
dass sich start und zielpunkt näher
kommen konkret muss sich die raumzeit
vor dem raumschiff zusammenziehen und
hinter ihm ausbreiten und da sich die
raumzeit selbst über licht schnell
ausbreiten kann könnte das objekt dann
in eine art blase mitreisen ein stern
der also zunächst hinter dem schiff lag
bis dann lichtjahre entfernten stern der
dagegen weit vor dem schiff lag ist dann
plötzlich in reichweite verantwortlich
dafür ist die kompression der raumzeit
mit dem raumschiff passiert dabei sehr
wenig es bleibt zu seiner lokalen
raumzeit matrix gesehen unbewegt und
schwimmt quasi auf der welle der
raumzeit mit das tolle daran die
passagiere bekommen keine probleme mit g
kräften und auch einsteins gesetze
bleiben unberührt so könnten wir dann
also schneller seien als das licht und
das wäre wohl eine der größten
entdeckungen überhaupt schon 1994 gab es
dazu ein modell in dem der ob antrieb
eines raumschiffs zehnmal schneller als
die lichtgeschwindigkeit war erdacht
wurde dieses gedankenspiel damals von
dem mexikaner miguel schalko bier
doch für dieses modell notwendig ist
eine lokale raumzeit verwerfung das
kostet eine unmenge an energie und fast
so viel nämlich wie die masse des
jupiters gespeichert hat um sie zu
umgehen könnte man den nordring
allerdings in donath vom entwerfen und
ihn in schwingungen versetzen diese idee
kam einige zeit später von einem nasa
physiker und zwar genau von unserem mist
arbeit doch hinzu kommt ein weiteres
problem denn man wusste nicht einmal wie
man die raumzeit konkret denen und
staufen könnte in dem modell von 1994
sprach von einem raumschiff mit
exotischer materie die rede dass man mit
negativer masse umgehen müsse denn die
würde dann gegen die gravitation angehen
doch wie genau soll sich eine negative
masse bilden wie soll sie aussehen wie
sollen sie entstehen fragen auf die es
bisher keine antworten gibt dieses
problem gehört mit der aktuellen
entdeckung der vergangenheit an es
handelt sich um eine echte wenn auch
extrem winzige und sehr schwache blase
so weit allerdings ist sie noch sehr
sehr klein und mit ihr sind reisen durch
raum und zeit unter keinen umständen
möglich deshalb macht weit deutlich um
keine missverständnisse aufkommen zu
lassen will ich das ganz klar sagen
unsere entdeckung ist kein analog modell
zur vorstellung einer blase doch weit
hat schon begonnen weiter zu
experimentieren er und seine kollegen
haben ein konzept für einen minijob
raumschiff entwickelt dabei besteht es
aus einer kugel durchmesser 1 mikrometer
und einem zylinder mit einem durchmesser
von 4 mikrometer also sehr sehr klein
und nur unter dem mikroskop zu erkennen
laut weit müsste es eine
dreidimensionale kasimir energiedichte
die den anforderungen des alko pia
modells entsprechend aufweisen und es
scheint tatsächlich kein hirngespinst zu
sein es wurde peer reviewed und im
renommierten european physical jogger
veröffentlicht allerdings gibt es
zweifel dr die sony weit forscht schon
seit geraumer zeit an bord antrieb und
dem em drive als eher ungewöhnlichen
antriebsarten 2015 sorgt ja schon einmal
für aufregung die nasa dämpfte die
erwartungen deutlich während die
experimente von forschern am johnson
space center der nasa in houston
weltweite schlagzeilen gesorgt handelt
es sich in wirklichkeit nur um kleine
anstrengungen die bislang keine
greifbaren ergebnisse erbracht haben so
die nasa damals gegenüber space.com
zudem arbeiten die nasa nicht ab ob
antrieb was aber damals nicht der
wahrheit entsprach weil ja weit genau
das tat und er war bei der nasa damals
angestellt inzwischen hat er die nasa
verlassen und arbeitet am limit l'espace
institut lsa wo er sich verstärkt der
grundlagenforschung mit mit fest steht
dass alles ist eine super komplizierte
physik und die forschungsarbeiten in
diese richtung machen eben hoffnung und
somit wären in der theorie zumindest
auch reisen zu proxima centauri
innerhalb von wenigen jahren
realisierbar doch der warp antrieb ist
immer noch sehr weit von einer
technischen anwendung entfernt dann von
mini nano raumschiffen zu tatsächlichen
raumschiffen dieser schritt in denen
astronautin astronauten dann reisen
könnte ist in jedem fall noch dass es
noch ein sehr langer weg und auch wenn
es immer mehr experimentelle
mathematische und theoretische arbeiten
dazu gibt sie alle könnten in eine
sackgasse führen oder sie werden
tatsächlich realität und vielleicht
werden dann schon interstellarer reisen
in diesem jahrhundert wirklichkeit
vieles wird schneller realität als wir
denken und neben künstlicher intelligenz
kranken computern könnte auch der warp
antrieb zu diesen rasanten entwicklungen
gehören mein buch per aufzug in den
weltraum beschreibe ich zahlreiche
solcher bahnbrechende entwicklung vielen
dank für inzwischen 100 bewertung das
buch gibt es hier oder in der video
beschreibung oder im ersten angebunden
kommentar einfach draufklicken und einen
blick in die zukunft werfen und zu einem
sehr konkreten bis dahin bleibt dran